salut les copains c'est moi bill est
claire je suis de retour avec mon
meilleur ami bull
vous voyez les familles que j'avais
adopté qu'elle est belle la baballe bibi
réussi à en faire une famille exemplaire
lui d'autres ont su sucre le peuple il
ya quand même quelques problèmes
d'élocution et la kro kro kro croquer
quand koke avec ses dents le sucre je
suis un chien je parle mieux que lui
mais depuis quelques temps ça tourne
plus vraiment être heureux
nous les artistes nous nourrissons de
notre malheur pour credo rien n'est
écrit les misérables au les gens riches
j'essaie de comprendre la hausse est
parti en cacahuète et c'est pas facile
il fait pipi sur de rhodia papa qu'est
ce qui lui prend
il vient en fait une bêtise alémanique
vous avez bonjour toi ça va en train
d'uriner sur mes chaussures
t comme ça s'est bien passé j'ai eu un
18ème histoire pour arrêter d'être un
petit garçon modèle
certes de l'ohada et ça continue encore
et encore
non mais tu vas arrêter petit insolent
qu'est ce que c'est que ces manières
poule et moi 2 et là encore c'est que le
début